para escoger hacia dónde vamos y cómo lo
queremos lograr la libertad de definir
nuestro camino como seres humanos
pero para ser libres como mucho de lo
que nos define depende de cómo nos ven
los de los demás pero principalmente de
cómo nos vemos a nosotros mismos
por lo tanto además de decidir que
queremos ser libres es requisito
indispensable que los poderosos respeten
nuestra libertad
yo vengo de un pueblo que durante mucho
tiempo se vio a sí mismo como menos que
los demás
vengo de un pueblo donde nunca habíamos
tenido el valor de tomar nuestras
propias decisiones
vengo de un pueblo donde nuestro destino
siempre fue controlado por otros
vengo de un pueblo que solamente es
dueño del país más pequeño del
continente americano
y que incluso esa pequeña propiedad
sobre ese pedacito de tierra que apenas
se ve en el mapa no es respetada por
países que tienen muchísimo más
territorio que a nosotros muchísimo más
dinero y muchísimo más poder y que
piensan correctamente que son dueños de
sus países pero piensan incorrectamente
que también son dueños del nuestro
y es que un grupo de países poderosos no
solo tiene mucho más que todos los demás
sino que también creen que son los
dueños de lo poco que tenemos los países
que no somos poderosos
es como si alguien viviera en una casita
muy pequeña y humilde
pero que tuviera un vecino muy muy rico
cuya casa es un hermoso gigantesco
palacio con inmensas extensiones de
tierra y tesoros inimaginables
quien vive en la pequeña casita respeta
y admira a su vecino no le molesta que
sea inmensamente más rico que él él está
feliz es su pequeña casita pero ha
decidido mejorarla pintarla arreglarla y
amo hablar la mejor como esfuerzo claro
pero está seguro que valdrá la pena
todo bien hasta ahí
hasta que el vecino rico decide que su
vecino pobre no tiene el derecho de
arreglar su casa no tiene el derecho de
comprar otros muebles o pintar las
paredes el vecino rico ha decidido que
no solo es dueño de su palacio sino que
también puede ir a dar órdenes a la
pequeña casa de su vecino pobre
y la orden es que todo tiene que seguir
mal como estaba antes los arreglos no
están autorizados
el vecino pobre no tendría por qué
haberse adversar a su vecino rico no
tiene por qué envidiar lo o aspirar a
tener lo que el vecino rico tiene no
tiene por qué pretender que irá a su
palacio a darle órdenes oa exigirle que
cambie el color de su mármol
pero el vecino pobre si debe tener al
menos el derecho de limpiar su casa
pintar sus paredes cambiar sus muebles
sembrar flores en su jardín y cambiar su
techo por uno que no tenga goteras y que
lo proteja de la lluvia
eso no puede molestar al vecino rico
él no puede exigirle que vuelva a poner
los muebles viejos que corte las flores
que despinte las paredes que quite el
techo nuevo que además les está
funcionando para poner el techo viejo
que había antes con el agravante que ese
techo con goteras nunca sirvió
el de siendo rico no tiene ninguna
autoridad para exigirle a su vecino
pobre que regrese al pasado
porque no tendría por qué pretender
mandar en casa ajena
en segundo lugar porque es el signo
pobre ya intento seguir las órdenes de
su vecino rico y no le pudo haber ido
peor
y en tercer lugar
porque lo que está haciendo está
funcionando por primera vez porque
debería su vecino obligarlo a regresar a
como estaba antes con qué objetivo para
lograr qué
acaso no debería estar feliz que su
vecino pobre esté un poco mejor que
antes
por eso digo que la libertad es algo por
lo que aún luchamos en nuestro país en
el salvador
porque si bien somos libres y estos
veranos
e independientes en papel no lo seremos
de verdad hasta que los poderosos
entiendan que queremos ser sus amigos
que los admiramos que los respetamos que
nuestras puertas están abiertas de par
en par para comerciar para que nos
visiten para construir las mejores
relaciones
pero lo que no pueden hacer es venir a
mandar a nuestra casa
y no sólo porque es nuestra sino porque
no tendría sentido deshacer lo que
estamos logrando
en poquísimo tiempo el salvador ha
pasado de ser el país más peligroso del
mundo
literalmente el país más peligroso del
a estar en camino a ser el país más
seguro de américa
pasamos de ser un país para muchos
desconocidos y los pocos que los
conocían los conocían por las pandillas
por los muertos por la violencia por la
guerra
pasamos de eso a ser un país conocido
por las playas por el sur por sus
volcanes por su libertad financiera por
su buen gobierno y por haber acabado con
el crimen organizado
y esos logros que apenas empiezan y que
se están consiguiendo en poquísimo
tiempo para nosotros son inmensos y
tenemos el derecho a continuar en el
camino de nuestro desarrollo
por eso dije al principio que la
libertad es algo por lo que aún luchamos
porque todavía necesitamos que se nos
reconozca nuestro derecho a ser libres a
ser independientes de verdad
quise utilizar este podium para decir
estas palabras porque tal vez no solo
resonarán en mi país el salvador sino
también en otros pueblos del mundo que
como el mío quieren construir su propio
camino con libertad
unos podrán hacerlo antes otros después
para uno para uno será más fácil para
otros será más difícil
pero será mucho más rápido si los países
poderosos nos ayuden o al menos si no
nos quieren ayudar que no estorben
cada pueblo debería encontrar su propio
camino
y cada pueblo encontrará amigos en la
búsqueda de ese camino
a esos países humildemente les ofrezco
la amistad de este pequeño país el más
pequeño del continente americano el país
del sur de los volcanes y de las pupusas
el país que aún lucha por su libertad
pero que está a punto de conseguirla
hace tres años estuve aquí en este mismo
podio me las naciones unidas en ese
tiempo les dije que este formato era
obsoleto y ahora tres años después nos
damos cuenta que lo es aún más
pero tal vez aún sirva de algo tal vez
sirve entre muchas otras cosas para que
este representante de este pequeño país
el más pequeño del continente americano
humildemente le recuerde que estas
naciones unidas- no se crearon para
dividir para destruir o para someter
sino para relacionarnos para trabajar
juntos para construir una mejor
comunidad de países y para buscar
soluciones a los problemas del mundo
pero con el respeto absoluto a la
soberanía y a la autodeterminación de
cada país y de la manera que dice la
misma carta de las naciones unidas en el
primer principio de cómo sería esta
organización la organización está basada
en el principio de la igualdad soberana
de todos los pueblos
y como dice uno de los principales
propósitos por los cuales se fundaron
las naciones unidas'
y fomentar entre las naciones relaciones
de amistad basadas en el respeto al
principio de la igualdad de derechos y a
la libre determinación de los pueblos
tal vez el cambio del mundo unipolar al
mundo multipolar del que tanto se habla
sea mejor si en lugar de pasar a ser de
una superpotencia a varias
superpotencias pasemos mejor a un mundo
en donde cada pueblo es verdaderamente
libre de construir su propio camino y
donde en esta comunidad de naciones
aportemos todos los grandes y los
pequeños desde nuestras experiencias y
nuestras capacidades a solucionar los
problemas de la humanidad
nadie pudiera estar en contra de eso
pero al igual que con la libertad fácil
es decirlo pero difícil es que sea
realidad
vine hasta acá a pactar me en este
podium en un formato en el que ya no
creo
para decir algo que lo más probable es
que de todas maneras no cambie la forma
que los países poderosos ven a los demás
pero tal vez si cambie la forma en que
los países en vías de desarrollo nos
vemos a nosotros mismos
si después de estas cortas palabras he
logrado algo de eso o al menos que un
puñado de individuos que se verán a sí
mismos con respeto y que sepan que son
capaces de construir su propio camino
entonces valió la pena venir hasta acá a
hablar en este formato obsoleto y quien
quita tal vez con el tiempo tal vez
surgen otras naciones surgen otros
pueblos que también decidan luchar por
su libertad
y entonces las naciones unidas- habrán
vuelto a ser relevantes al menos para
este humilde servidor
muchas gracias y que dios bendiga a
todas las naciones del mundo